when did you start doing comedy started  on comedy at 18. what were you doing  before that selling sneakers yeah were  you any good i was one of the best  sneaker salesmen in the world i say you  sneaker like that tell me what you want  nine and a half what do you do you run  you wanna i got a bad ankle right now  what do you supinate or pronate does  your foot roll inward  i'm i'm married i don't do either one of  those okay well i'm going to assume that  if you got bad ankles you probably  pronate so what i want to do is i'm  broke  with stability my stability i'm talking  about something with condensed eva maybe  polyurethane i would recommend a salcona  sunken needs a strong shoes i would also  [Applause]